who are the Kaiden riders that Patrol  Lim grave the word Kaiden actually  refers to the name of their home  settlement which is located somewhere in  the mountaintops of the Giants far to  the North  so what are the Kaiden doing so far from  home well the Kaiden are mercenaries so  their purpose is tied up with whoever  they fight for and most of the time they  seem to be fighting on behalf of the  undead Nobles these wealthy Nobles once  hailed from Lane Del a place that shares  a border with the kaiden's icy home but  after the shattering these Nobles  abandoned Landell to go and pillage the  ruins of distant civilizations surely it  is said they were in search of something  once but whatever it was has long been  forgotten so in the end the Nobles have  become stuck in an undying search for  this thing that they will never find and  it's quite possible that the Riders are  tied to that hopeless purpose